[Music]
on this Saturday night the situation
spiraling in Sudan
Canadians hold up in the capital as a
ceasefire crumbles
scared uh trying to keep together the
efforts to get everyone out
plus the new air passenger Bill of
Rights ready for landing it's a very
very strong and good report the sweeping
steps to improve your experience on
board
also tonight the aftermath of a small
plane crash in Quebec
Toronto Raptors reset it's tough for a
guy who in this first year wins a
championship to kind of live up to any
expectation you put on after that head
coach Nick nurse out Paving the road
back to a winning roster
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we start in Sudan where the Army has
told four Nationals and diplomats to get
out after a U.S and U.N brokered
three-day truce broke down
more than 400 people have been killed
and More Than 3 500 injured since
fighting between a paramilitary group
and Sudan's Armed Forces erupted two
weeks ago airports have been turned into
Battlegrounds so getting out is next to
Impossible nearly 1600 Canadians who are
stuck in Sudan are being told to shelter
in place until help arrives
Consular services are limited and
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
says the situation on the ground is
extremely volatile and is rapidly
deteriorating Metro lay has our top
story tonight
major Muslim holiday of Eid was supposed
to provide a reprieve for
conflict-ridden Sudan a ceasefire had
been agreed upon between two warring
generals vying for control of the
military
instead Khartoum was clouded in dark
smoke with prayers interrupted by the
sound of machine gun fire the head of
the army spoke on radio of the need for
a peace deal
in this war everybody loses he said we
need to sit as Sudanese to find the
right way out to restore hope locals and
expats alike have stayed indoors since
fighting erupted a week ago
vesnavukovic a Canadian teaching music
in Khartoum says her balcony was damaged
following an explosion in a neighboring
building the fighting she says is
everywhere the absolutely had no idea
what we can expect next hour we are
scared uh trying to keep together trying
not to panic what she needs is
information while she says her
colleagues from the U.S Britain and
France have been apprised by the
respective governments of evacuation
plans vukovic says she's registered
three times with the Canadian consulate
and heard nothing so far
so far that most of us
emails from Canadian registrate abroad
Canada has suspended operations at its
Embassy and foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie tweeted that Canada is
ready to support Regional efforts to
resolve the conflict the standing rapid
deployment team has arrived in
neighboring Djibouti to provide
logistical support for the Canadian
government and at least one more plane
is on route to the region
but as the fighting shows no sign of
cooling off Global Affairs Canada has
yet to confirm if there is a plan to
evacuate the roughly 1500 Canadians
believed to be stuck in the middle of
what could become a civil war Mike
trolley Global News Toronto
recent Pentagon leaks suggest Canada has
no intention of meeting its NATO
commitment to spend 2 percent of its GDP
on defense and that's prompted a group
of defense and political figures to
write an open letter urging Canada to
meet its International obligations on
this week's the West block Eric Sorensen
spoke with two military commanders who
say Canada must act now and he joins us
with more on this Eric
pharah did prime minister Trudeau tell
NATO officials Canada would never meet
it's two percent of GDP Target as
reported in leaked documents by The
Washington Post the PM wouldn't confirm
I continued to say and will always say
that Canada is a reliable partner to
Nato a reliable partner around the world
and but whether he said it or not the
actions of the government speak volumes
says the former commander of the
Canadian Army Andrew Leslie this week on
the west block all you have to do is
look at the results in terms of the
Canadian Forces Readiness which is
woeful by the way and you see that the
current government has not spent what is
required to get our Armed Forces with
the equipment the training and the
number of people that they need
to meet commitments among the six
largest economies in NATO Canada lags
behind the other nations in military
spending as a percentage of its GDP well
below two percent the government says it
is increasing spending by billions on
f-35s on Norad expansion and to arm
Ukraine but the Canadian military is
stretched thin a letter from senior
defense and political figures says
Canada must take NATO defense spending
more seriously with mounting threats
posed by China and Russia General Ray
ano once LED NATO's military committee
all of the Nations have to step up
so to speak and
the only way that they can do that is
share the burden that that comes with
with belonging to Nato Canadians have
long accepted Canada's limits on defense
spending but do you think Canadians
views are changing on that
I do this is the most dangerous time
since the end of the second world war if
there's any severe miscalculations there
could be World War III the government is
currently conducting a defense policy
review the fourth review in 18 years top
officials hope this time will be
different with the future of Canada's
defense at stake Farah
Eric Sorensen and Ottawa thank you Eric
the head of the Union representing tens
of thousands of striking federal workers
is calling on the prime minister to get
involved in the negotiations
what's happening today should have
happened on day one of bargaining two
years ago
not today when we have over a hundred
thousand members out on the picket line
that is totally unacceptable I've never
seen I've been involved in this Union a
long time I've never seen a round of
bargaining like this the disrespect at
the table from treasury board and from
this government
in a statement the treasury board says a
new offer was presented today and both
sides have resume talks
two men are in critical condition after
a plane crashed into a neighborhood
south of Montreal it happened at about 7
30 last night in San Ramis police say
the aircraft hit a house electrical
wires and a parked car before crashing
into a second house the injured men were
on the plane and no one else was hurt
and the cause of the crash is still
under investigation
ahead of another busy travel season
there are some new recommendations being
studied in Ottawa that are supposed to
improve air travel for passengers
especially when their flights are
delayed or canceled sounds great right
well as Tim Sargent reports not everyone
is convinced that this guidance will
actually be implemented or that it'll
lead to any sleeping new changes so
buckle up
foreign
some sweeping steps are being taken that
are supposed to dramatically improve
your air travel experience and thank you
Minister a parliamentary standing
committee is trying to put more power in
the hands of passengers especially if
flights have been canceled or delayed
21 new recommendations are designed to
strengthen the passenger's Bill of
Rights the emphasis puts the burden of
proof on airlines to justify why
passengers shouldn't be compensated the
highlights offer compensation to all
passengers affected by delays
cancellations or denial of boarding make
compensations through payment rather
than travel credits and communicate
problems and resolve complaints in a
timely manner I think that would be
awesome because just in my situation
that I've been dealing with it feels
like I absolutely have no rights at all
crystal dariano is a thrilled new
recommendations are being made she was
one of many Canadians whose flight was
canceled last month when four planes of
player Airlines were seized dariano had
to rebook with another carrier to get to
Florida with her boyfriend she's been
partially refunded by complains trying
to recover the balance has been
extremely frustrating pretty much every
little thing that they can do to not
refund this a passenger rights advocacy
group also endorses the findings it's a
very very strong and good report but
there are still fears that the
recommendations won't become law the
government is just engaging in another
uh more even more smoke screen and even
less transparency in the complaint
process in its statement to Global News
the National Airlines Council of Canada
writes that it agrees to strengthen the
overall air travel system for passengers
however it urges the minister of
transport to consult with Airlines prior
to making any decisions the transport
Minister insists he's looking at it all
before making any final decision we will
see these uh uh that the passenger Bill
of Rights strengthened before we rise
for the summer
and for many hopefully more powers for
passengers as they make their final
getaway plans for the summer vacation
period some Sergeant Global News
Montreal
the U.S Supreme Court handed both the
Biden Administration and abortion rights
Advocates a victory last night in a
majority decision the court will allow
mythopristone commonly referred to as
the abortion pill to remain available
without restrictions as Reggie shakini
reports the victory is only temporary
I'm in a much larger legal battle
in this new post-row America where
reproductive health is intertwined with
partisan politics a rare win was handed
to abortion rights groups on Friday
after seven of nine justices on the
country's highest bench allowed Memphis
pristone to remain available without
restrictions in states where the
procedure isn't banned that is very
important in ensuring reproductive
Health well the Biden Administration and
the drug manufacturer lauded the move
it's not the end of the road this ruling
was merely procedural with the ultimate
decision on accessibility being handed
back to the lower courts once the case
is in fact heard on the merits then the
court weighs in on a substance that will
tell us what happens for other drugs
at the core of this fight is safety the
FDA approved mifa pristone 23 years ago
and it's become the most commonly used
medication for abortions in America but
a Texas judge sided with an
anti-abortion group who says the drug is
dangerous and wanted band Dr Nikki zeit
who penned a declaration for the FDA
refutes that there was no actual
evidence it was all anecdotes from
Physicians who don't use the medication
um so we are in a world where The
Surreal is real legal experts say a
court deciding to ban a drug could
tarnish the fda's reputation and open
the door to other approved drugs even
contraception to face a similar fate
this case is fundamentally about
expertise and the degree to which we
trust scientific officials lawyers say
this one win does not indicate how the
rest of these cases will be decided
rather it shows a more cautious approach
to a topic that's been politically
charged one that could again prove
problematic for republicans in the next
election with the party caught between a
conservative base and a reality showing
broad public support for abortion Farah
in Washington thank you Reggie
the nature economy coming up while
protecting the planets and making a
profit are no longer at odds
it's Earth day today and as activists
across the planet call for greater
Environmental Protections in this
country there's a growing movement
embracing the so-called nature economy
it relies on conservation and
stewardship to protect economic growth
and to drive up tourism by Saving old
growth forests and placing a price tag
on the environment and gaviola unpacks
the new approach
trees as big as buildings in BC's
Coastal rainforests are prime targets
for loggers but proponents of the
so-called nature economy suggest leaving
them standing is more profitable than
cutting them down we understood that you
know 500 year old trees don't just grow
up overnight the nature economy puts the
environment first to promote economic
growth placing a price tag on clean air
wildlife and plants traditional economic
models don't value things in nature
until they're processed for human use
the nature economy is Niche though
increasingly being considered in
boardrooms across the country but it's
voluntary and not standardized our
economy if it continues on its current
task will effectively bring ruin to the
very ecosystem that we that our
civilization kind of kind of grew up in
clean energy Champion Tom Rand says the
financial and business Community need to
fully understand the cost of
Environmental inaction
one example cod fishing once a thriving
industry in Atlantic Canada overfishing
led to its collapse in the early 90s the
long-term Financial ramifications are
felt to this day there's nothing
inherently against valuing nature within
capitalist economies you just need to
put a rule in place that values it and
then you would act accordingly so it's
really all hands on deck emergency call
for Action Economic Development has
often been thought of as either a
development or conservation approach
both of these can be used in tandem to
create an opportunity where growth and
development are actually accelerated at
a pace that we've never been able to see
before the amount of money that's
currently being invested the smart
Prosperity Institute estimates annual
investment in Canada's nature economy is
more than 5 billion dollars but needs to
increase to 25 billion when we think
about things like floods or natural
disasters investing in nature can help
mitigate those types of disasters and
create a better bottom line for these
businesses
the challenge getting people to
understand that the investment pays off
over time and gaviola Global News
Toronto
[Music]
ID 19 connection ahead are people in
infected with the virus at a higher risk
of suffering from diabetes
while many Canadians may be moving on
from the covid-19 pandemic Health
experts remain concerned over the
long-term effects from getting infected
with the virus and now a new study is
examining its mysterious link to another
disease diabetes as Catherine Ward
reports evidence suggests covet is
increasing the risk for the chronic
condition and it's not entirely clear
why
experts are unraveling the full scope of
covet 19's long-term implications and
the latest finding is an increased risk
of a serious chronic condition people
who were infected with covet that they
had about 17 to 22 percent higher risk
of developing diabetes compared to those
who did not have choline this isn't the
first study to examine the link between
the two diseases but it is one of the
largest looking at more than 629
000 people
that 1 in 20
people who are living with diabetes
during this time that could be related
to their covet infection the data
doesn't tell us that covid-19 causes
diabetes and researchers say more study
is required but experts do have a few
theories about why more diabetes cases
were found in people who had coveted 19.
one possibility could be that the kobit
19 virus might be affecting the pancreas
which makes insulin and that is one of
the ways that the body manages sugar
levels and and prevents it from getting
diabetes another hypothesis is that
people who were diagnosed with covid-19
were overall more likely to get sick and
then be followed by doctors they're more
likely to be hospitalized and they're
more likely to be seen by doctors over
the next year or two which is more
opportunities to get a test for diabetes
so it's possible that infection just
might have increased the ascertainment
the detection of diabetes more
frequently compared to non-infection
with cases on the rise experts say
understanding why diabetes happens is
critical unfortunately and sadly
diabetes rates are rising slowly about
25 years ago it was closer to one in 20
people having diabetes and now we're at
one in ten and one in five over 65. well
many questions linger researchers say
the link gives doctors more clues about
what to watch for long term and that
would help us to Think Through through
how we monitor people and how we could
advise people in terms of reducing their
risk Catherine board Global News Toronto
[Music]
Raptors at a crossroad next replacing
head coach Nick nurse in what's needed
to replicate that winning chemistry
[Music]
there is a lot of uncertainty for
Canadian basketball fans after this
week's big news about the Toronto
Raptors despite leading them to their
first and only NBA Championship in 2019
star head coach Nick nurse was fired on
Friday an arguably expected bombshell
giving the team's failing performance
this season
togetherness all the things that I think
culture we have stood for here I think
we lacked this year all I think about is
how you win you know like I almost think
that sometimes we almost have to like
validate the championship we won
the 18 faces many questions
years ago
joining me now from Toronto to talk
about nurses Exodus NBA TV host and
producer Akil Augustine okay thanks so
much for joining us I want to start with
reaction first so what's the reaction
being to nurses firing in the basketball
world
well it's split down the middle some
people are surprised because they
thought the Raptors would continue down
the path they have still a year left on
his contract and some people after the
press conference in Philly kind of
thought the writing was on the wall and
uh you know the table was set for nurse
to make his exit
well you know he's been at the helm for
almost five years obviously his tenure
was marked with ups and downs but he did
steer the Raptors to their first and
only NBA title in 2019. how else will he
be remembered
he'll be remembered as exactly that the
man that brought Toronto its very first
championship
um the hell has been of one of the
greatest Raptors teams ever known
unfortunately things just didn't seem to
live up to the expectations and again
it's tough for a guy who in his first
year wins a championship to kind of live
up to any expectation you put on after
that because you know you've kind of
done it all right yeah that's a really
good point uh you know as you mentioned
I mean the Raptors have not been able to
replicate that success so what do you
think has gone wrong and and what needs
to happen uh to to get them back to the
top I mean a lot of people are saying
there's a need for a big trade here
well I think the first thing um that you
could say went wrong was when Messiah
Jerry had his postseason press
conference he said he didn't enjoy
watching the team play and people
um you know you take that to heart when
you know probably the most famous rap
through outside of a player is the
general manager he's a big piece of the
brand and if he didn't enjoy what he saw
in the court and he's the boss you know
you gotta you know pay that um a lot of
attention and I think again I go back to
the expectations of this group I think
there's a lot of talents some holdover
pieces like pascals the active and
friend Ben Fleet from that championship
team and people wanted to see a lot from
this group people were hoping the
Raptors can continue to be a team that
would be competing with the Boston
Celtics and the Philadelphia 76ers for
you know a spot the Eastern conference
championships and hopefully you know
after a little bit more work maybe the
NBA finals and that just didn't seem
like it was happening to this group the
big question I think for for all fans is
I mean is another NBA title achievable
for the Raptors in the near future and I
know you don't have a crystal ball but I
mean is that years away how long would
that take
uh I mean listen that's the that's the
number one goal for messiah jiri he said
in his press conference he wants to
validate that first 2019 championship
and make sure that people don't think
it's a flash in the past that this is an
organization built around success it's a
couple years away at least do I think
it's next year and obviously not I think
it's gonna have to uh reassess things
and and kind of restock the cupboards
and find that talent that can get into
that threshold and look for that
opportunity a la the Kawaii move maybe
but I think with the amount of talent we
have in the front office the basketball
Minds have been put together
um I trust that this group has the
ability to steer us towards another NBA
championship but that is going to have
to be patient you can't be spoiled
all right Akil great talking to you that
is Akil Augustine uh host and producer
for NBA TV appreciate it
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your candidate
is Cape Spear Newfoundland and Labrador
we love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com until tomorrow
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
foreign